The armed forces of the Russian Federation
continue a special operation in Ukraine
over the past day at the blocked
Azovstal metallurgical plant in
Mariupol,
771 militants of the nationalist
unit of the Azov surrendered to captivity on May 16,
1730 militants surrendered, including 80 running, all
those in need of treatment
receive assistance from medical institutions in Donetsk
of the People's Republic in Novoazovsk and Donetsk of the
operational-tactical army aviation
I was hit and two command posts
as well as 58 areas of concentration of
manpower and the Ukrainian war tags in total
, more than 340 nationalists were destroyed as a result of air strikes
2 units of military equipment withdrawn under construction by
rocket artillery troops hit
six command posts
295 districts save the turning of manpower of
military equipment of the armed forces of Ukraine
43 activist and mortar Ukrainian
units in firing positions and two
electronic warfare stations with
Russian anti-aircraft
equipment  rons in the areas of settlements
Volchiy Yar borshchev to Veliky Khutor Small
passages of snowballs to and Petrovskaya,
Kharkov region, Chernobaevka and
Novaya Kakhovka, Kherson region, were destroyed by 15
Ukrainian barren secret bars